foreign
[Music]
how do you grow the economy
most agree on the ingredients ideas and
Innovation investment infrastructure and
skilled individuals to deliver them and
everyone says we need more of it
but Britain has a growth problem more
than a decade of stagnation since the
financial crisis
and the only G7 economy still smaller
than before the pandemic changing
economic course in a rapidly changing
World maybe the biggest challenge facing
the nation
in the Deep Freeze could be the future
of medicine these are human cells grown
to order in a lab outside Cambridge
that's pushing the boundaries of Biotech
developing a platform for coding and
creating human cells from scratch with
huge potential for research and
treatment that could one day enable 3D
printing of organs or restore the use of
Limbs to spinal injury victims what bid
bio has created what is a process by
which we can recreate every human cell
type
bit bio is also a model for precisely
the sort of growth the government says
it wants but with almost no available
lab space in Cambridge the UK's planning
regime stands in the way
they put a new building up and you know
the the space is snapped up immediately
it's extremely competitive we had to
pull a lot of strings and in order to
get to this incredible beautiful site
that we are here at beaverham there's
constraints when it comes to of course
infrastructure and support of
infrastructure whether it's
manufacturing elsewhere you would get
governments that pay for your
manufacturing infrastructure I don't
believe that's very common in the UK
Cambridge and its twin Oxford are among
the UK's growth success stories sharing
a global reputation for academic
excellence and Innovation and historic
wealth and privilege making the most of
these natural advantages should be an
economic no-brainer
Cambridge and Oxford's about 90 miles
this way already engines of growth and
there is a plan to try and share that
success to better link it up with towns
in between like Milton Keynes and
Bedford build a new Railway line and
plenty more homes but there's a problem
most of this land is green belt and you
don't have to drive very far before that
grand economic Vision bumps in to the
local political reality
this is South cambridgeship District
Council
where nothing is more controversial than
putting the new homes and workspace the
economy needs and their constituents
backyard this is Cambridge
industrialized that's why we're special
that's why we're different
and Mr Nick version let us know if is it
in attendance
thank you very much that plan called the
Oxford Cambridge Arc has been opposed
every step of the way good counselor
Smith also explain what development
proposed Oxford Cambridgeshire
partnership is seeking to deliver if not
the excessive housing her local plan
proposes
providing enough homes to meet the needs
of the workforce as serious consequences
we already have greatly inflated rents
greatly inflated house prices so we
don't want to force people to live
elsewhere councilor Daniel lentil is
among those who think the ark billed as
a British Silicon Valley is more about
property than National Prosperity you
cannot put a california-sized biohub on
an East anglian Market town without
doing a bucket load of damage the point
is not no growth the point is good
growth and you can't get good growth if
you're not working with people with
place instead of trying to concrete over
the slightest concern that we don't have
enough water here
the opposition has already bulldozed a
target of one million new homes and
plans for a new road and is now focused
on East-West rail which will link Oxford
and Cambridge using existing and
restored lines and new track across the
bedfordshire Greenbelt this is the sort
of low density spalling stuff that that
they want to do across the ark and so on
and then behind in the Green Field you
can just see before the trees that's
where the two routes for East West rail
will go
there's no such economic reality as the
ark there's a successful University
cluster in Oxford and there's another
one in Cambridge the piece in between is
90 miles that's three times as long as
Silicon Valley it's the best and most
profitable place to build houses in this
country
by the end of the decade East-West rail
should arrive here
cambridge's biomedical campus the Arts
Advocates say it's crucial to provide
homes and transport for future expansion
and maximize growth beyond the
university towns
we know that there's strong evidence
that connecting your clusters is
generally a good thing so we have World
leading Global capability in both Oxford
and Cambridge and we also have some
clusters within the rest of the arc we
have a space sector we have a motorsport
sector we know that joining those up
will create better opportunities for
collaboration it provides a wider area
from which to draw skills every job
created in Knoxville or Cambridge
creates more jobs outside of the area as
well
all this is intended to encourage
investment but domestic Capital may be
missing out on Innovation happening
under its nose
bit bio has already raised 200 million
dollars but just 175
000 of that was British money the
funding environment in the UK is
extremely good at creating startups but
it's not very good uh to to support
scale-ups uh and especially it's not
geared towards creating large companies
which I believe that's what the UK
requires also for their economic growth
most of our Capital actually all of our
Capital apart from the initial precede
funding is
from Excel so mainly U.S capital some
overseas Capital also from from Asia so
there's a tiny amount of UK money less
than one percent
a global race to attract investment this
should be the easy bit
if the UK is going to be a global leader
in the knowledge economies of the future
it won't do it without Cambridge or
Oxford or London perhaps a bigger
challenge though is trying to take what
works here and replicate it in parts of
the country that have been left behind
200-mile Drive North to Rochdale is a
three-hour journey across the gulf that
opened when Britain's cities
de-industrialized
cotton and canals made this in 19th
century Boom Town but today productivity
lags behind the national average so does
disposable income and GDP per head and
male healthy life expectancy is 10 years
lower than in Cambridge closing these
gaps is a social imperative and huge
Economic Opportunity
[Applause]
places like this might be part of the
answer this is or will be atom Valley an
industrial development to attract
Advanced manufacturing and Material
Science back to Greater Manchester back
by the mayor Andy Burnham
you look at Manchester City Center now
you look at the skyline that tells a
story about the potential of this place
of ours it's not too big a statement to
say you know we could lead the
re-industrialization of the north of
England as we move towards a net zero
Society we led the way before why can't
the north of England lead the way again
businesses like CR Solutions are already
doing highly specialized work building
bespoke robotic production lines for
everything from medicines to aircraft
they need most of all is people with the
skills to help them grow
if you struggle to recruit the people
yeah immensely yeah so much so that
we've decided to go with a more organic
route and grow our own Engineers through
apprenticeships and degree
apprenticeships
you could you could hire people right
now you could cut the capacity if you
could find them absolutely we can have
designers Fitters we could hire a range
of vocational and non-vocational skill
sets yeah through mechanics software
right through the whole gamut be on time
English and math yeah we've got this
call aren't we the production line for
workers starts here see you later
we've got some great employees but but
it is warehousing and Logistics Julia
Heap has lived in Rochdale all her life
as principal of Hopwood Hall college she
wants to transform the town by
developing the skilled Workforce
required to interact investors we want
to build relationship with employers at
a really early party I want to look at
them if they're coming new into the
borough look at what their skills needs
will be look at what the rules will be
we can come into heart to our students
come and talk to our staff and we can
shape a curriculum shape the curriculum
with them yeah absolutely
sixty percent of the students at Hopwood
Hall come from deprived postcodes High
skilled high-paid jobs could change that
and there's plenty of ambition
my main goal is to eventually learn how
to weld and electronics as well but to
also have my own engineering firm in the
greenhouse growing up watching from one
having that goal and being in it for my
industry before I get really weird and
artistic about it it's almost like a
sculptor sculpt in their own creation
I've been looking around for
apprenticeships closer to home and
there's just it's like Manchester and
stuff so if they are closer to home like
Rochdale it'll be imagine
take it anywhere really you know you get
your experience behind you stick out for
your apprenticeship qualifications can
go abroad you can just
look for better opportunities in this
country the skills are all transferable
as well across different fields of
engineering so could go anywhere with it
do you think you can fulfill your
Ambitions around here oh yeah 100 born
in the right place at the right time I
suppose
the traces of the industrial past when
the North West led the world aren't hard
to find but the canals were a reminder
that technology moves fast and economies
need to keep up
there's no question the UK faces a
chronic growth and productivity problem
but it is hugely uneven between London
and the southeast and everywhere else
and changing that really matters not
just to individual Prosperity but to the
public finances and sustaining Public
Services there is huge potential to do
more but it needs the right incentives
the right support and political will
Britain hasn't got one growth problem
it's got several and they need their own
Solutions our second cities need to
realize their potential
a new Devolution deal that covers the
powers to create a london-style public
transport system the powers to create
the UK's first integrated technical
education system free us up is the
message I guess free us up we can be
more than we currently are in a
competitive global economy business
needs to know what investing here means
it's about stability and certainty is
corporation tax going to go up for the
next 10 years or do you have a plan to
bring it back down and people the UK's
prize assets
need the tools and opportunities to
thrive I want more money in in the
budget for further education you know we
were funded uh fairly we could invest in
our staff in terms of training retention
these are complex issues and tough
choices for fixing growth was easy we'd
have done it by now but Britain can ill
afford another generation
of stagnation